let's take a look at the continued
downfall of Ron DeSantis the Republican
Florida governor who is polling about 20
percent in the Republican primary more
than everybody but Trump but would
seemingly no path to actually securing
the Republican nomination Ron DeSantis
was interviewed by Fox news's Stuart
Varney or Fox businesses Stuart Varney
this is a kafka-esque moment I apologize
I apologize it is kafka-esque uh Stuart
Varney mentions to DeSantis listen
you're down over 30. how are you going
to catch up what's your strategy and
DeSantis just attacks the media I don't
know that this strategy has winner
written all over it you're down over 30
points to Trump what's your strategy for
catching up
well first I think it's pretty clear
that the media does not want me to be
the candidate I think that they've tried
to create narratives that somehow the
race is over this is going to be a
state-by-state contest we've worked
really hard to build the type of
organization in places like Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina that you need
to actually be able to win these early
contests and we're going to continue
doing that we got a lot of work but
we've had very very favorable uh
response and we're going to keep
building off that momentum at the end of
the day I think the fact that I'm the
one that's targeted by the media by the
left even by the president of Mexico
listen if the strategy is I'm going to
pretend to be a victim just like trump
it pretends to be a victim I guess he's
doing it but I don't know that this is
going to get them too many votes because
people know that I will beat Biden and
they know that I will actually deliver
on all these issues and beat the
Democrats at the border beat up folks
this is really low energy you're down 30
to Trump what's your strategy for
catching up well it's mostly the media's
fault but I'm gonna beat Biden well
you're not even gonna face Biden unless
you figure out a way to make up a 30
point gap on Donald Trump if I want to
be as charitable as possible to Ron
DeSantis he seems to be saying when he
says it's a state-by-state contest 30
points nationally don't matter if I can
win Iowa and or New Hampshire and
justify staying in this race it's not
looking like he can win Iowa or New
Hampshire but let's put that aside if I
want to generously say that's a strategy
okay I guess that's a strategy which is
forget about the national polling just
focus on those critical States during
this disastrous interview Stuart Varney
actually asks DeSantis
is there is is there any climate plan
that you have listen to what he says the
headlines are just full of stories about
wildfires smoke extraordinary
temperatures in the southwest and the
southeast to some degree do you have a
climate plan
it's going to be to rip up Joe Biden's
Green New Deal I think at the end of the
day we need to embrace American domestic
energy this could be a huge source of
National Security economic Vitality it
can build our industrial base in Florida
we've actually had a huge reduction in
emissions but it was done through
Innovation it was done through Market
forces not command and control so we'll
go about that in a much different
direction now you might be surprised
about hearing that he's going to do away
with Joe Biden's Green New Deal and the
reason you might be surprised is there
is no green New Deal now if you press
them on this and you say the green New
Deal isn't the law what do they say they
usually say something like well Joe
Biden has integrated elements of the
green New Deal into the inflation
reduction act as well as by executive
order but then if you really press them
it's very difficult to actually make
that uh a believable
um a believable argument so as I've said
before not ready for prime time does not
have winner written all over him has
absolutely no tangible explanation as to
how he's going to make up the 30-point
deficit and he's only running against
Joe Biden and the funny thing is he's
running against Joe Biden and against
things Joe Biden hasn't actually done
you've got to figure out a way to win
one state here bro and it's not clear
that he's figured that out and meanwhile
there are problems in Florida Trouble in
Paradise let's talk about that next one
of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zippix has already helped
tens of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpicks.com today save 10 percent
with the co code pacman10 at checkout
just remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below